The Joe Rogan experience
in working on music,
I was off fucking around competing and
paint ball tournaments that could get
into painful. Oh Man. Uh, yeah.
I had a team called stone to assassins
and it was competitive paintball at the
time. I was, you know,
training, uh, martial arts as
I've done throughout my life.
And,
uh,
I was also playing competitive paypal
and a martial arts we're doing showed a
con. I started off with taekwondo
and I got sort of, I mean it's,
it's like, it was, uh, it was,
the Dojo was cool, you know,
and I was progressing quickly,
but I sort of fell out with the master
there with the sea floor or whatever.
I can't remember what Nim, yeah. And, uh,
one of my partners who I grew up with who
is one of my partners in our Dr. Green
thumb, um, Brandon,
whatever his father, um,
was, uh, was, uh, you know,
Sensei and his sensei
and became my sensei.
I went from taekwondo to show con and
I started training with him. I mean,
he had been in the Dojo since he was
five years old training with this father.
So, you know, I came into that, it took,
it took a little bit of a convincing
for me to go from one thing to another
because it's such a different
style. Um, but you know,
I adapted to it and I liked it and it
was, um, very different, less flash.
But, uh, it's very disciplined in,
in his father. You know, he was,
you know, born in Japan, raised out
there and he, he, you know, their,
their shit is kind of different.
They go to, to, to, um,
martial arts universities and they get
degrees in different martial arts so they
can go and take like,
okay,
hop Quito in Jujitsu and showed
O'Connell and all this and,
you know, get their, their
degrees, you know, they work,
they were up in the belt
system and all that stuff,
but they become teachers through,
through that university,
I guess as fascinating.
And, uh, yeah, his,
his father was one of the guys in
one of the federations that, uh,
he's one of the three or four senses that
have to come in and give you the black
belt when you actually get
it. Ah, yeah. It, what was it,
a s k FFA or something like I
got this done karate federations.
Yeah, something like that. Yeah.
So you could imagine when Leo Machida
came on the scene, you know, we were like,
yeah, someone representing
the style that, you know,
we were training under anything yet a
lot of people got excited when he came
about.
He was really the first guy to legitimize
karate in the modern era of mixed
martial arts. You show like if you
could do all those other things,
if you could stuff take downs and you,
you knew submissions and all those things
on top of that, you could live. Yeah,
you could.
And you could do it in a weird way that
people didn't really understand his
timing. Yeah. Wonderboy Thompson similar
to that too. It's got a weird timing.
Weird timing. It's, it's, you know,
and then the faints with the hips.
He was good with that shit.
Like, you know, he, he would
throw people off with that.
And you know, we, I just happened to
go see his fight against Rashad Evans.
Oh Shit. And a man. I mean,
it surprised all of us. I
mean, we thought he would win,
but we didn't know he would win
in that fashion. I mean, yeah,
he was something special, you
know what I mean? And he's doing,
he's over at Bellator now,
right. With his brother.
His brother Chins has been over
there for awhile. His brother,
I think his brother's at Bantam weight
or featherweight, one of those. But, um,
yeah, that, that,
I think it's good to go from taekwondo
to other styles because taekwondo gives
you a lot of dexterity. You want, I'm
going to move your legs easily. Yes,
absolutely. It's a good foundation.
Yeah. It's a good way to start off.
It's good for little kids to the
guest that doesn't, you know,
there's not a lot of head contact
or not as a nation to, yeah. Yeah.
And then when you learn, if you weren't,
if you really actually want to fight,
you want to learn more. Tying all those
other things you have way quicker. Legs.
Yeah. They just move better.
Yeah. For me, you know,
I was never good with all those flashy
kicked kicks like that. So, you know,
big dude. Yeah. It was harder for me.
Tae Kwan doe like the show
Khan was definitely hard,
but it was more suited for
someone my size and style.
The of hardstyle it is style. And He,
you know, he, when he was training as,
he would not let up because he'd go be
reels here, let me go light on him now.